Le Kansas regorge d'hommes bons Je ne veux
pas être un homme bon Je veux être un grand
accompli quoi que ce soit
Je rêve que tu es à Oz J'adore la
bonne sorcière où est ton balai ici en savoir
beaucoup sur quelle est la ville stérile
sont enfin là et la
prophétie s'accomplira c'est ma sœur evanora
je suis ici pour vous servir le trésor royal
d'Oz il vous appartient mais seulement après
avoir vaincu la méchante sorcière à quel point
elle est méchante les villes ont été détruites les
enfants sont devenus orphelins  grand sorcier du
Kansas j'ai attendu que vous veniez arranger les
choses moi ces corbeaux ont juste dit que
nous allons mourir votre magie est la seule
chose assez forte pour nous sauver tous
s'il vous plait dites moi que vous messieurs pouvez vous battre
non ne soyez pas  en disant que les gars prennent le mien je
ne suis peut-être pas en
fait pas besoin de créer le mien nous
lisons depuis
je pense que je pourrais être
toi